OK.
Let's get into audience questions for the
week, one that is increasingly coming up in
different forms.
Is this question of Donald Trump and the federal
government versus states when it comes to
shelter in place, stay at home orders and
shutting down versus reopening the economy.
And the question is, it was received received
today from Mark was.
Hey, David, if Donald Trump wants to reopen
the economy before state governors are willing
to.
Is there any way Trump can overrule a governor?
Stay at home.
Order.
I did a bunch of research on this and the
answer to me strikes me as no.
From all the legal opinions that I've read
about this, so Trump can do what he wants
federally.
He can say we're going to extend the guidelines
to April 30th, as he did last week over the
on his Sunday press conference.
And when it comes to federal employees, Trump
has certain authority when it comes to international
air travel.
It doesn't appear as though, for example,
if if Trump bans travel from China to the
U.S., it doesn't appear as though Massachusetts
Governor Charlie Baker could say, no, no,
no, we're going to allow planes from China
to land at Boston's Logan Airport.
Doesn't seem to be the case.
Trump's designation sort of rules or supersedes
whatever a local government governor might
want to do there.
Of course, you've got the FAA regulating air
travel as a federal agency, but I think you
sort of get the point.
Governors do not work for the federal government
nor for Donald Trump.
They are administrators of their state.
And we have states rights here.
So if Donald Trump says everybody's got to
get back to work and Charlie Baker here or
Andrew Cuomo or Gavin Newsom or whoever says,
no, we're not going to do that.
It might seem as though there is a very significant
conflict there and it might sort of become
a fight.
Now, the reality is that these shelter in
place orders are not really being enforced
significantly by police at this point other
than in some cases where there have been no
big gatherings that police broke up in arrested
people for the most part.
And in Massachusetts, we have experience from
the Boston marathon bombing when there was
a shelter in place, when the bombers were
on the loose.
These are basically things that are followed
by people not at the end of a barrel of a
gun, so to speak.
And in in that same way, I believe that there
is not really any way for the federal government
to come in and do the opposite and say, you've
got to go to work now.
And I'm pretty confident in Massachusetts.
If Trump said, let's read, let it rip.
And Charlie Baker says let's not, that it's
not even going to be an issue that people
are simply going to do what Charlie Baker
says.
Now, the most likely outcome from a legal
perspective, if the Trump administration wanted
to push it, imagine that federally Trump lifts
the guidelines and governors say we're going
to keep doing our thing and we're keeping
things close.
The federal government could sue a state that
happens.
There are lawsuits between federal and state
governments very regularly.
And the litigation would take a very, very
long time, likely longer than the Corona virus
shut down would last in any of these states.
And in the meantime, states would remain closed.
There's one other element I want to talk about.
The 10th Amendment has an antique commandeering
interpretation which prevents the federal
government from having local police enforce
federal laws.
So, for example, when California decriminalized
is or legalizes marijuana, it's illegal federally.
The federal government doesn't tell you no
Santa Monica police to go enforce the federal
illegality of marijuana.
They send in the DEA or the ATF or whoever
it is that they send in federal agencies in
the same way National Guards are administered
at the state.
Who is it that the federal government would
send in to enforce at the state level that
the federal government wants things reopened?
Hard to imagine.
So on a practical level, I believe governors
would have the upper hand if they decide to
keep things closed on a legal level.
It could be a fight.
It's a fight that legally could take years
and would long outlast the actual likely durations
of these stay at home orders.
Shelter in place.
Nonessential business shut down sort of thing.
That's my best estimate.
Now, one other thing to mention.
I read one take online that said now, you
know, the federal government could enforce
that.
Businesses must open under the commerce clause.
I found no serious legal analyst that was
willing to to to make that case.
And it strikes me as pretty bogus.
But if you disagree, if you believe that there
is a way that the federal government could
enforce an open everything order, even if
a governor doesn't want to let me know.
I don't see it.
I haven't found a single.
Credible legal expert that sees it that way.